The Joe Rogan experience.
Russell,
why is it then when people start getting like super spiritual,
they start dressing like you.
You dress like a guru.
We circulate a memo so it's now time to stop wearing shocks.
Stop shaving and make eye contact for a bit too long.
Oh,
it uncomfortable archive.
Stary how long are you going to go with the beard?
I mean that's,
that's like you're,
you're full on like you're a Yogi.
No,
I mean he's gone beyond Jesus and into Moses and less a profits or test or a
navy seal.
You are in that range too.
Like he could be some wild man.
That's,
that's a mistake that would like if there was an assault course in front of us
that have the potential for me being a navy seal would start to break down.
I once went on a,
an assault course with some US marines in that place near San Diego.
I can't remember the name of that base and climbing up that rope using your leg
muscles.
It was not good value and enjoy it.
I like the camaraderie and I really like I as I've written about and talk about
quite a lot when I'm around very in very male environment,
I kind of really like it.
I really get off on it,
but I have to watch for myself not getting too excitable.
It's even in this environment.
As a matter of fact,
I have to clean myself a little bit.
Chilled out.
Why?
What do you mean?
What does it do to you?
Well,
I guess what it is is my early life,
I grew up mostly around my mum and dad have brothers and sisters and stuff like
that.
So my male role modeling occurred later in life and I think it probably relates
to this spiritual thing.
I think it meant that I was,
I'm very open to sort of spiritual experience,
meditative experiences.
I didn't have a lot of grounding physical experiences or bodily experience.
He's really till adolescents until sex and sexuality and as the first time I
really got into the body,
didn't do sports as a kid,
didn't have like main guy,
right?
This is what we do,
this how we shave.
This is how you treat people.
They say,
you know,
I didn't really get that kind of education.
So now still if I'm around like soldiers,
UFC fighters,
I go,
you know,
I'd be BJJ primarily as a result of these conference where there's not Colum
confrontation cows conversations.
That's a much nicer term.
So like there's a bit of me that's the guy gave excited about the analysis of
it.
It's not homo erotic because that doesn't happen to be the way that I roll out.
Just enjoy a little too much.
There's something about it fired up and it may be what's bad about it,
what's,
what's bad about getting fired up?
Nothing for me except like,
you know,
look my,
as you know,
my model for life is as sort of a 12 step model about watching my impulses.
My impulses of got me in a lot of trouble.
My impulse is to take drugs,
my impulses to sleep around my,
like my impulses to even eat food.
I've got sort of a tendency to get obsessive.
But you know,
you would probably argue that if you direct that energy correctly,
it can be kind of positive.
I think it can,
but I agree with you that it can get out of control and I have similar impulses,
I have similar problems and I just used
disciplined and hard work,
especially working out to try to mitigate it.
Well that's why I pick up from you is that your early encounters with martial
arts of men that you've understood from a young age.
It seems to me physical discipline and I think that's a very important thing.
And I'm only learning that like now because I've had a real like you know,
drugs then fame there and,
and chaos.
And I said I've only just emerged from like the sort of the fog of that madness.
Okay.
I love how you have emerged though cause it's very unique.
You've,
you,
you've uniquely emerged authentically like you.
This is who you really are.
Like you're not putting on an act you found yourself,
which is like what everybody wants to do.
They want to find themselves.
I mean it never feels like a completed task right.
It.
Now.
Everyone's a work in progress forever.
That's right,
but you are,
you like you are very comfortably you and you've found what makes you you.
That's a lovely compliment to get from you,
Joe.
I appreciate that because what I think about is that you're a very different
type of person that made it things that in this world,
in these political times,
you and I would be supposed to,
I would say a take adversarial stance.
His on,
I'm Vegan now,
you love hunting,
but my personal philosophy is my morality and my spirituality is for me.
It's not something I'd go around inflicting on other people and telling them how
they should behave.
I'm Rick.
I know enough now to know people are different,
people had different experiences and I don't let those things get in the way of
how I evaluate other people
for why we should all be more like that.
I really,
I really believe that.
I mean there's so many people that I disagree with that I have fun conversations
with a,
I don't think there's anything wrong with that and,
and I don't think that impulse to to have antagonistic engagements with people
that you disagree with is correct.
How else are we going to consolidate?
Yes.
I feel like it's just like I'm only going to deal with people that see the world
roughly how I do.
How are we going to have a full new tribes,
new alliances,
new relationships,
new system to a time when evidentaly it feels to me at least Joe,
like things are breaking down.
Yeah.
There's a law bit in this as Serby and confrontation and people don't want to
talk to you.
Yeah,
but I mean,
I don't know how real that is of actual people.
I'm talking,
I suppose about how the media landscape seems to present information.
I don't know if that's true when you're,
you know,
when I'm around people,
I don't sense.
Oh Wow,
these guys are really tied up in Brexit or Trump or whatever.
It doesn't seem that relevant toward an airy people.
It seems to me that people are still operate in on a,
in a person or how are you today?
Are you okay?
You know,
people are willing to get on like that.
I mean,
how are we supposed to take these ideas on board?
It's almost too vast for us.
Right?
Geo political ideas that were asked to identify with
Ryan and then your everyday life hardly ever affects you or affects you very
little in comparison to things that you ignore because you're concentrating on
Brexit.
Are you concentrating on Trump or you're concentrating on whatever it is?
Yeah.
That wall build that wall,
whatever it is.